Sometimes filmmakers hide obscure in-jokes
so subtly that it takes a few viewings to
spot them, if you're able to spot them at
all. These hidden gags might just make you
want to watch these flicks all over again...
Shaun of the Dead's spoilerific beginning
The zombie horror-comedy Shaun of the Dead
opened the Cornetto Trilogy with a hilarious
look at how a British slacker and his pub-loving
friends handled the zombie apocalypse. But
if that lovable loser Shaun could speak Hindi,
he might have been clued in to the impending
zombie apocalypse when he went to the convenience
store.
(radio broadcast playing)
The radio broadcast in the store actually
reveals that the dead are coming back to life
and attacking people. That joke is so well-hidden,
it's practically buried treasure.
Nite-Owl saves the Waynes
The opening sequence of Watchmen has a pretty
awesome reference to a famous caped crusader.
Check the frame featuring Nite Owl punching
a masked gunman outside of an opera house.
The Gotham Opera House. Yes, it's Batman’s
origin! In the background is a rich couple,
clearly meant to be Bruce Wayne's parents,
Thomas and Martha. The opera bills read "Die
Fledermaus," German for "The Bat." And just
to make the joke a little more obvious, several
posters advertise the first issue of the Batman
comic book on the wall as well. Holy Easter
eggs, Batman!
Sherman and Peabody
There's a subtle reference to other time travelers
in Back to the Future, but you wouldn't get
the joke unless you stayed in the theater.
When Marty travels to 1955, he crashes the
DeLorean into the Peabody's family barn. The
members of the Peabody family poke their heads
into the barn, at which point that little
boy claims that Marty's time machine is actually
a UFO. If you watch through the credits, you
see that this boy's name is Sherman—Sherman
Peabody, a reference to the cartoon time travelers
Mr. Peabody and Sherman.
"Quickly Sherman!"
Unlike the DeLorean crashing into the barn,
that joke flew right over most viewers' heads.
Lord Farquaad
Even though he's in a movie for kids, Lord
Farquaad from Shrek was given that name to
get a laugh out of the adults. If you didn't
catch the joke, here's a hint: try saying
his name over and over.
"I am Lord Farquaad."
"Lord Farquaad?"
Farquaad, Farquaad, Farquaad.
That’s right, he's a complete f***wad.
Imagine how Disney chief Michael Eisner felt,
considering the villain was reportedly based
on him...
The Despicable...Lehman Brothers?
While the Financial Crisis of 2008 wasn't
funny, the creators of Despicable Me thought
a joke about it wouldn't hurt. If you have
eagle eyes, you probably noticed that when
Gru enters the Bank of Evil to get a loan,
there's a small sign that reads "Formerly
Lehman Brothers"—a jab at the global financial
services firm that went bankrupt and filed
for Chapter 11 in 2008.
Kevin Smith's Jaws References
Director Kevin Smith is a film buff, and he
likes to show it. Want proof? He sneaks a
boatload of Jaws references into his films.
Like the Clerks salsa shark.
And Mallrats' characters, Brodie Bruce and
T.S. Quint.
And Chasing Amy's Hooper X.
He even takes it a step further in Chasing
Amy with an homage to the scene where Jaws'
characters compare scars.
The twist? Instead of showing battle wounds,
Banky and Alyssa compare scars they received
while romancing the ladies.
"You're gonna need a bigger boat."
Thanks for watching! Subscribe to our YouTube
channel to watch more videos like the one
you just saw. And leave us a comment to let
us know which obscure movie jokes you think
should've made the list...